Wait a minute.
You ain't heard nothing yet.
You ain't heard nothing.
You want it.
This moment in the jazz singer in 1928
led to standing ovations in movie
theaters.
The first moment of dialogue marked at
the beginning of a boom in the motion
picture industry improving sales from
1928 to 1929 despite the beginning of
the Great Depression.
Okay.
Warner brothers surged and profits from
2 million to 14 million a year as
millions flock to these talkies,
which for the first few years consisted
mostly of musicals.
Talking provided a layer of realism
missing and movies by allowing more
character development and plot
innovation in radio and television
writing paved the way for strong
dialogue driven movies.
12 angry men is written in such a way
that you can follow the entire story
with your eyes closed.
Oh can to chalk and told even when it's
an open and shut case like this one
image of the innocent which drug about
no.
Well I guess their own title,
Nick tensity and pace.
That's impossible for a completely
silent movie to achieve.
I want to talk about dialogue and look
at how dialogue enhances the story while
also seeing its limitations.
Probably the biggest immediate benefit
of dialogue is it's just so damn
efficient.
Hello,
are you captain with me?
Whatever you're doing in Arizona,
I'm joining Richard Lord Vick.
He's there with his truth.
The lock narrowed and accurate with
Mallory,
he's been I to have to drive far right.
That's the next top of the stage coach.
You'll be with your husband in a few
hours
from 10 seconds of dialogue.
We know who lucy is,
where she is,
where she's going and why she's going
there,
what her husband does,
where her husband is,
where the stage coach stops next and how
long it should take until the couple is
reunited.
Dialogue is quick and easy,
but exposition through dialogue runs the
risk of being boring like when we have
to sit through a villain monologuing his
evil plan through a computer.
I think voiceover narration can be a
lazy substitute for strong,
efficient dialogue on screen,
although sometimes there is no other way
to do it.
There are right and wrong ways to do
exposition dialogue.
Let's say a character,
his parents died.
Shit dialogue.
Tell us like this.
Oh,
well mama good.
I don't know.
They're,
they're gone.
They died when I was three.
Remember?
Or like this,
uh,
leave it.
Both
mom would allow it.
Expositions should be descriptive and
also not completely plain.
It's the difference between saying
something and revealing something.
I call it the dead parent test for
dialog because so many movies seem to
have trouble telling us a parent isn't
around anymore.
My mother's name was Susan.
She was killed in a car accident with my
father and they're both dead.
So stop trying to bring up dialogue.
Should reveal a character isn't in the
picture.
Instead of just saying it out loud,
it doesn't always have to be through
dialogue
and it can even be comedic.
Oh.
And she inexplicably mails me a cactus
every Valentine's Day and I'm like,
thanks to heat,
coyote ugly.
This cactus Graham stinks.
Even worse than your abandonment,
but it just has to reveal something
instead of saying it,
it passes the dead parent test if it's
not completely dry.
Because frankly just saying is lazy
writing.
Yeah.
And with the number of lifeboats times
the capacity you mentioned,
forgive me,
but it seems that there are not enough
for everyone on board.
I think the same idea goes for dialogue
that explores the movie's made sure
ideas.
Interstellar is a gorgeous movie,
but this dialogue is very heavy handed
and just being set
is the one thing we're capable of
perceiving that transcends dimensions of
time and space.
Maybe we should trust that even if we
can't understand it yet,
maybe it's better to have themes hidden
and more ordinary dialogue
and fuck the Air Force Academy.
If I want to fly,
I'll find a way to fly
or revealing the teams through visuals.
Dialogue always serves a narrative or
comedic purpose.
No matter how random it feels,
impulse fiction,
the dialogue feels meaningless,
but it sets up major plot points and
conflict.
Vinson and jewel's have a 10 minute
conversation about whether or not it's
cheating for a man to give a woman a
foot rub
and look,
I can even a million ladies and then
your foot massages and they all meant
something.
Or we act like they don't,
but they do.
I mean,
it's just so fucking cool.
That is a centralist thing going on
where where you know you don't talk
about it,
but you know what?
She knows it.
Fuck Marcella.
Snoop and Antwan should've fucking
better known better
this conversation while at the surface,
very casual reinforces that Marcellus
walls is not to be trifled with as
Vincent spends his night with Mrs.
Wallace,
that earlier conversation reminds us
that the stakes are high and Vincent May
or may not be overstepping his
boundaries.
Well Dan,
you're going to shit.
Good night.
I've had a very lovely
walk out the door and get in the car,
go home,
jerk off and I saw you going to do
Tarantino uses dialogue to show
character flaws.
Jolson,
Vincent,
get a Great Cup of coffee and praise it
in an attempt to be polite to Jimmy.
All it does is make him mad cause jewels
and Vincent are not focused on the
crisis they just created.
But you know what's on my mind right
now.
It ain't the coffee in my kitchen.
It's the dead nigger in my garage.
Their signature swab and charming
dialogue failed them.
But Winston Wolfe,
he knows the appropriate way to respond
because he's the wolf.
Terentino's dialogue has masterfully
layer.
They may be talking about nothing,
but in actuality the dialogue
foreshadows the major conflicts in the
rest of the movie.
You shoot me in a dream,
you better wake up and apologize.
Don't listen to anybody that says
dialogue is bad and visuals are always
better in film.
It's just false.
Dialogue is beautiful,
revealing at hilarious.
Just know when to use it.
I am the Walrus.
Shut the fuck up.
Donnie,
the island and bladder Murry Elliot
Joliet off the fuck is he talking about?
If you like this topic,
you should check out channel Creswell's
video on the same idea.
He talks about dialogue with even more
depth than I did.
Also a big thanks to all my patrion
supporters and follow me at my
ridiculous twitter handle.
Swag thug for life.
Thanks for watching.